here with reaction joey jones and former
trump white house chief of staff mark
meadows i
once governor abbott started sending him
to d.c and then new york and ron
desantis jumped in and he's sending him
all over the now to martha's vineyard
the best political jiu-jitsu move i've
ever seen mark meadows and i've been
doing this a long time
well it's not only a good political move
it's it's actually
making those democrat governors
and mayors actually start to beat
border states and cities you know you
mentioned d.c
when
buses started to arrive in washington
d.c
all of a sudden the mayor of d.c is
declaring an emergency uh because she
hasn't had to deal with it in arizona
and texas now she's dealing with she's
calling up the national guard
and demanding
without a dollar
without a doubt but but with governor
desantis actually uh delivering them to
to martha's vineyard we're we're going
to see a whole new awareness on a
sanctuary state where all of a sudden uh
this open border kind of mentality that
is not serving our country well uh is
coming home to roost now on uh martha
martha's vineyard where you're going to
see a whole lot of people start to say
wait governor you're not doing the right
thing well he's doing precisely the
right thing and showing the hypocrisy of
it all well mark let me do a follow-up
with you how long will it be before
these
governors mayors etc become racist and
not want to have these illegal
immigrants in their town cities or
whatever
well here's the thing is as soon as the
money doesn't arrive whether it's
emergency relief or anything else they
all of a sudden they're going to be more
conservative than some of my
conservative
former colleagues and so
they're going to plead for money first
plead for relief second and then all of
a sudden they're going to change their
tune
you know joey you were raised in dalton
georgia you enlisted in the marine corps
after high school
you served your country for eight years
and
you know during your deployment in
afghanistan you were responsible for
disarming and destroying 80 ieds
thousands of pounds of other unknown
bulk explosives and you stepped on and
initiated an ied resulting in the loss
of both of your legs
you define to me
heroism and i know to this audience you
are the very definition of it all
and i i like your your viewpoint now
we're telling service members we're
giving them instructions because they
can't put food on the table because
we're not paying them enough money the
people that protect the freedom of these
kids to go to school we're going to take
their money to pay for their education
but they can't put food on their table
and the government joe biden's
government is telling them to go on food
stamps that's what that's what their
plan is for our military that's their
way to say thank you
you know it's embarrassing sean it
breaks my heart really
we have an all-volunteer service that
every single day gets harder and harder
to recruit not just because people don't
qualify anymore but because they don't
want to we just spent 20 years fighting
a war that our own government can't
properly explain as to why it took 20
years to fight it or why we were there
to begin with in some cases so the
government's got its back against the
wall they should really be rolling out
the red carpet to recruit talent into
our military because not only do we have
a problem with getting troops we've got
a problem we've got a void in leadership
we're hurting on true leadership the
pentagon should be strife with people
pushing back on the partisan politics
coming into it from all five sides but
that's not what's happening they're
embracing it because they believe as
leaders that are politically appointed
as generals that that's their way to the
top their personal ambition is
outweighing protecting our country
because this entire country from coast
to coast has gotten very comfortable
watching other people's kids fight wars
and generals have gotten very
comfortable watching wars on skype from
the pentagon rather than on the ground
with our troops and that's a problem and
it's a problem that only a hardship like
what ukraine has gone through or other
places in the world could fix and that's
not what we want we don't want a war to
come to our shores that happened in 2001
we just marked 20 20
more than 20 years since then we don't
ever want that again but the way we
prevent it is by having a military that
is not only ready and well fed and happy
but also tough and ready to ready to go
to war and intimidating across the world
we're not focusing on those things and
that's the problem listen i don't care
what your what your sexual orientation
is i don't care if you're a man or a
woman i want you to want to lay your
life down for this country and be ready
to rise up to a standard not be brought
down to one i don't want the military to
look at you and say oh well you know if
you want purple hair i guess we'll let
purple hair if you want jewelry i guess
we'll let jewelry you don't have to keep
your hair out of the way so that
gear doesn't snag on it that's fine wear
a ponytail that's okay oh you need an
exemption for this any exemption for
that this doesn't make you a bad person
but it can make you a bad soldier it
can't make you someone that sticks out
and the time that you're in the military
you should want to blend in and be
another cog in that machine and that's
all that's how you become a part of
something bigger than yourself and we're
going to ask our citizens to join this
military and then say and you might not
even be able to buy food that doesn't
work sean so mark what the u.s army has
released is guidance for soldiers
as they fight inflation and they make
the suggestion about the snap program
the food stamps program and they say
well service members in their family may
be eligible the guidance said
pointing soldiers to the snap website
and phone number quote with inflation
affecting everything from gas prices to
groceries to rent some soldiers and
their families are finding it harder to
get
by on their budgets that they've set and
used before uh that's the guidance
they're giving the guidance we're giving
them is we're gonna tax you we're gonna
take your money and we're gonna pay off
a loan that somebody willingly took on
and you can go get food stamps and we're
not going to we're not going to pay you
enough money to put food on your table
and you're risking your life for your
country i can't handle that
well we're better than that sean and
listen whoever's giving that advice uh
you know you had senator kennedy on and
he's got some of the best one-liners
i'll use one of his that advisor is the
reason why there's directions on a
shampoo bottle it's just idiotic i can
tell you when we start to look at all of
this we have got to do better than this
and right now they're so slow rolling
everything in in the senate chuck
schumer slow rolling the defense
authorization and when we start to see
this they got a raise under president
trump they're getting excuses under
president biden sadly well i can tell
you joey jones i know you're in touch
with a lot of people in the military i
know i speak for probably 98 of this
audience there's a few liberals that
watch but i in saying
our soldiers deserve better before we
give money to ukraine before we pay off
student debt uh before we go with green
programs and solar panels and wind
turbines uh how about we pay our
military first
uh thank you so much 87 000 irs student
uh agencies
we invest in that yeah
we could have hired border patrol agents
and then we could get probably more
illegal immigrants to martha's vineyard
that would be a good idea all right
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else